anything you want to say about your dad
or to the fans or to anybody
uh you know uh it's it probably would be
important to touch on
uh those reunion rumors from maybe a
year ago
uh that were very real
over since 2015 i'd been talking with
dad
and was introducing the idea because
like he knew i was doing my music
so i would be like hey dad you know it
would be cool hear me out
you know it would be cool is what if i
opened for you guys
and we had mike come back and initially
my dad was like well you got to be up
there too
you can you know and eventually i was
like okay well maybe i can come up and
we can play
you know one or two songs from a
different kind of truth like we can
figure it out
but as time went on he warmed up to the
idea i got him
excited about it and at a certain point
it turned into
what we joked as the kitchen sink tour
because after he was okay
with that arrangement it was like [ __ ]
then let's get dave and hagar and even
sharon and let's just do a giant
[ __ ] awesome thing
and we talked to irving azoff about it
and how cool it would be and then of
course
irving you know got it ready and
everything and he he reached out to mike
before i had the chance to
uh because we wanted me to do that
and that's kind of how everything
started to get leaked out but by that
time
dad wasn't able to right
it's things started getting really bad
uh at the beginning of
2019 right after my birthday he got in a
a motorcycle accident that was from
we found out that he had a brain tumor
and uh but then
we took care of it he got this crazy
procedure called a gamma knife
radiation procedure and he was okay
but as time went on it just [ __ ] kept
stacking up
and stacking up it just
never let up ultimately
2017 was was kind of the start of it all
at the end of 2017 he he was diagnosed
with stage four lung cancer
and the doctors were like you have six
weeks
and then he went to germany overseas and
whatever the [ __ ] they do over there
it was amazing because i got i got three
more years with them wow
that's kind of important to let people
know that yeah that was real and we were
so excited about it
all of us it just uh
didn't pan out
you